why are there not more stories of
grown-ups using drugs the full spectrum
of drugs that we're talking about why
why isn't there so we talked offline
about Joe Rogan he's somebody who
started smoking weed later in life which
is an interesting story like when he's
already very successful and he has a
very interesting way of describing his
experience with weed that it was like
enhancing just productivity it actually
I think he says like it increases
anxiety a little bit in a way that was
productive like paranoia and not anxiety
and so that's an interesting story of an
adult talking about the use of weed for
for productivity purposes
but you don't get those stories very
often why
um I think fear people are afraid that
they will be uh belittled uh dismissed
all of these things as a drug addict or
some negative thing but cannabis is
lightweight come on uh you can you can
admit cannabis these days and the fact
that I don't know when Joe started but
if he did start later in life that's
cool I mean you are mature developed
um you have developed some
responsibility skills all of these kind
of things this is a good thing
um you don't want people to engage in
any kind of behaviors when they're young
and immature that might put them In
Harm's Way and so we want people to be
um developed at least I mean whether
it's uh being in a relationship with a
partner uh or whether it's driving an
automobile all of these things that can
be potentially harmful but extremely
beneficial if you are responsible enough
to handle them you want people to be
mature so that's a good thing so how are
you supposed to like somebody like me
somebody like Joe how are you supposed
to understand what the dangers are what
the negative effects are so you said
automobile
relationships
I think I have uh
reasonably it's crappy but reasonable
understanding of All the Troubles I can
get within relationships and what things
to avoid same thing with driving a car I
have no idea I'm in the dark in terms of
what
are the things to be careful about what
to avoid with drug with drug use when
we're talking about the heavy drugs
have you ever drank alcohol yes that's
true I know I drink a lot but I
understand that because culture like
came up
I was taught a lot of like this is what
you don't do and this is what you do
yeah this is when you drink a lot I mean
you see the effects you see the there's
a lot of negative examples there's
positive examples of social stimulant
there's examples of great artists using
um alcohol to sort of I don't know to
help be the Catalyst for that magic
moment for you know all of that I don't
I have some examples now
especially in America the same with weed
more and more you're starting to get a
lot of Stories on uh of the psychedelics
of different kinds there's um
psilocybin where you have uh mushrooms
or even MDMA used sort of positively
that's kind of like negative
stories from the past about acid about
LSD being used ultimately for productive
like uh for productive ends but it
destroyed the person that's kind of how
the story goes it was like a trade-off
you take uh it's like uh what is it
Robert Johnson soda sold to the devil to
learn guitar like it's a trade-off you
could take the drug you're going to
create some good stuff but you have to
pay for it those are the stories that's
some [ __ ] we tell children come on
that's exactly right you're exactly
right these fairy tales these cautionary
tales that we tell people
we have to grow up that's what the book
is about drugs drug use for grown-ups
um you know we tell people Pinocchio if
you lie your nose grow who believes that
who believes that there are fairy tales
but that's exactly what these stories
are they're in the same vein as those
kind of stories as Pinocchio
um you know like you said when you were
learning about alcohol you were told
what to do what not to do so forth the
same can be true with MDMA with cocaine
with Heroin the same is true because
there are some times when you there are
some potential dangers that you should
avoid and I wrote about some of them
um certainly in my work just throughout
all of my writings we I talk about those
kind of things and other people talk
about these things the problem is
is that we're getting our education from
[ __ ] sources from people who believe
in this kind of Pinocchio thing and it
just does not fit with the evidence and
the evidence we all publish in a
scientific literature all these things
that I'm saying
it's there in the literature I mean like
a place like Colombia we give these
drugs thousands of doses every year
do you think we would be doing this and
we do this with research grants that's
public that's funded by the public
taxpayers dollars do you think we would
be allowed to do this if these drugs
were so dangerous
um it's just nonsense I mean and the
drugs we're talking about
they are all approved for medical use
somewhere in the world
and the studies you conduct are
basically asking what kinds of questions
so you take uh the full range of drugs
you're talking about uh from from
marijuana to South Side into MDMA to
cocaine and heroin what is the study
looking at like what the actual
experience with the positive and
negative effects of the experience on
the drug are in the control conditions
yeah so we did these kind of experiments
with alcohol nicotine all these drugs in
order to have an empirical database to
tell people
um uh exactly what these drugs do and
what they don't do the conditions under
which the drugs will produce positive
effects the conditions under which the
drugs were more likely to produce
negative effects all of this information
is important for our society to know uh
and and we do know and and that's why
we're collecting the data we're
collecting the data it to help us with
treatment if someone is having problems
with these data uh hopefully we'll
understand more about
how to help them deal with their
problems based on some of the research
that we're doing